here in New York police have been
cracking down on protesters outraged
over a man's violent death on a subway
train 30 year old Jordan Neely a former
Michael Jackson impersonator who was
homeless died after being put in a
Chokehold by a marine veteran it was all
caught on camera and now the grand jury
is considering charges a warning the
video is disturbing Nancy Chen has the
story
[Applause]
it's erupted in New York again Monday
night
the death of 30-year-old Jordan Neely
Neely was homeless with a history of
mental illness
Witnesses say nearly was acting
erratically on the subway last week
screaming about being hungry and tired
out of the club that's when video
lasting nearly three minutes shows
Marine veteran Daniel penny with Neely
and a Chokehold
as at least one onlooker warns it could
be fatal
Neely was pronounced dead at the
hospital his death ruled the homicide I
think what happened is things got really
out of control but horrible accidents
sometimes can turn into a manslaughter
former Manhattan assistant district
attorney Michael bochner the testimony
of the other people on the train have
endangered they may have felt how
heightened and really kind of scary and
aggressive the whole situation was that
could lead to the conclusion that he
acted in self-defense a lawyer for the
24 year old says Daniel never intended
to harm Mr Neely and could not have
foreseen his untimely death Jordan's
story could be anybody else uh anybody
else's family member anybody else's
loved one uh could be dealing with these
issues Neely's family says Penny needs
to be held accountable what would
Justice look like for the Neely family
so Justice immediately means an arrest
it means following the process through
and letting Daniel Penny have a day in
court where he tries to prove that none
of this is what we all know it to be a
murder
when this happened an NYPD spokesperson
mentioned nearly did have an extensive
record of arrests the former Manhattan
assistant D.A we spoke with tells us
that likely would not be a factor in a
potential case unless Penny somehow knew
about Neely's history when he
encountered him on the train and this
has brought up so many conversations
especially about mental health and the
resources that are devoted to it
yeah and whether Jordan Neely should
have been on that train at that time
after seeking help on many occasions
according to the reporting that's out
there his family wanted help for him he
was hearing voices and it's we have a
system that is porous and people fall
through those holes and they end up in a
situation where this never should have
happened to him right he also never
should have been there yeah when you
start pulling back the layers of mental
health and what we're doing for those
that are struggling with it yeah right
about that when you look at that video I
can think of is he's dead and why it's
yeah it's very tough
Nancy thank you very much very complex
story